it's dominated talk about the Biden
presidential campaign for weeks and it
wasn't going away former Senate aide
Tara Reid claims she was sexually
assaulted when she walked with
then-senator Joe Biden an allegation she
only made public in the last few weeks
an allegation Biden could no longer
ignore no it is not true I'm saying
unequivocally it never never happened
and it didn't never happened I don't
remember any type of complaint she may
have made it was 27 years ago and I
don't remember nor does anyone else that
I'm aware of Democrats have been pushed
to address the allegation in the last
few days Speaker Nancy Pelosi who
endorsed by Dennis week insisted she has
new doubts about the former vice
president I had a great comfort level
with the situation as I see it with all
the respect in the world for any woman
who comes forward Republicans accused
Democrats of double standards saying
they were ignoring the allegation
against their presidential hopeful while
they piled on when Supreme Court justice
Brett Cavanaugh was accused of sexual
assault before his eventual confirmation
more than 20 women have accused
President Donald Trump of sexual assault
he was also caught on tape bragging of
assaulting women he denies all the
allegations and offered tepid support to
Joe Biden at the White House on Thursday
you know it could be false accusations
like know all about false accusations
I've been falsely charged numerous times
and there is such a thing one political
analyst says Republicans will use the
one allegation against you o Biden to
continue to attack him one of the things
that the Trump people do in their
strategic maneuvers is they don't try to
claim to be superior they try to create
moral equivalences so they say you're
just as bad as I am which makes you a
hypocrite which makes you worse you know
and you know it's very effective what
they do Joe Biden knew he could no
longer ignore the allegation against him
he's ahead in the polls particularly
with women he'll be hoping by addressing
it now
one continued to be an issue in
November's election Alan Fisher al
Jazeera Washington